[Music]
as we told you earlier the weekend's
mass shootings in ohio and texas have
renewed calls for gun control
legislation
president trump talked about gun
violence and ideological hatred this
morning so let's discuss it with a key
member of congress south carolina
senator lindsey graham chair of the
judiciary committee he joins us from
greenville south carolina welcome
senator
thank you for having me i'm here at the
greenville gop we had a
good talk tonight about a lot of things
yeah we're going to try to do that with
you as well i first want to get your
reaction to the weekend's
um events and of course as predictable
plenty of reaction on both sides of the
aisle that's political in nature
well number one the people to blame are
the shooters and nobody else is a sick
and senseless crime and
there's a common pattern in many of
these cases people are disturbed they
take the law in their own hands they're
full of hate and
they act out and it's time for us to act
you know calling the president names is
not going to solve this problem
for the last 24 hours it's been really
over the top
i'm looking for a democrat to work with
not to insult
so i'm hoping i can find some democrats
that will work with me
starting with the idea of red flag laws
i think these
protective orders have a lot of hope to
solve some of these cases
well i want to put up a map now so folks
can see where there are a number of
states that have done this across the
country of course there are always
concerns about due process a lot of
people have
that guns could be taken second
amendment rights could be potentially
violated before people have a chance to
make their side of the case
how do you thread that needle well
number one
indiana was one of the first states to
do this
here's what we do this is not going to
be a federal law to be a federal grant
program
to get the federal grant you have to
have due process
there has to be an imminent threat of
harm to oneself
or to others before the police and it
can only be the police can go to a judge
you have a hearing you gotta have more
likely than not standard
there's an imminent threat of bodily
injury seven days later you have a
full-blown hearing
clear and convincing evidence where the
gun owner can come in and defend
themselves and the government has to
prove
by clear and convincing evidence that
their the person is disturbed a danger
to themselves of others
and if that test is met they can seize
the guns and get the person the help
they need
in in parkland florida cruz had 32 to 40
visits by the cops
they had no way to stop him he did
everything but take an ad
out in the paper or kill people so what
i want to do is encourage these laws
with robust due process
and i think that's the president's goal
also well he talked about that today he
talked about trying to unify
and make this a not a partisan issue but
to find bipartisan solutions on the hill
that's been really tough to do i want to
play something from former democratic
congressman luis gutierrez today
talking about first the discussion was
in the context of the war on terror and
he says it's really the domestic issue
we have to look at
and he's not buying what the president
was selling today here's what he said
yes we need a war a war on
terrorism here in the united states of
america
to eradicate but the first thing we need
to do is the president of the united
states
has to stop has to stop igniting the
flames of hatred and bigotry
and division in this country i don't
believe any of what you said today
senator where is the bipartisan space to
get something done
well i've worked with senator blumenthal
and we're getting close we're going to
run it by the white house we've talked
to gun owning owner group so we talked
to the cops
and we're trying to come up with a
serious solution to a serious problem
we're trying to empower police officers
to do something before it's too late
with plenty of due process we're not
trying to take anybody's guns away from
them
we're trying to get guns out of the
hands of people who are dangerous
who actually may kill themselves or
somebody else that's the goal we're
trying to shut down these social media
sites
that spew hate we're trying to find
solutions and for the last 24 hours it's
been pretty
disappointing to hear all the rhetoric
directed at president trump
president trump is not the problem here
the congress for years has been talking
it's now time to act
and if senator blumenthal and i can come
up with a package
that has protections for the gun owner
but allows the cops to do something
before it's too late i hope we get a
vote in the senate and it will pass
okay i want to ask you about some
foreign policy issues as well while we
have you
the president last week talking about
the fact that listen he campaigned on
bringing our troops home from a number
of conflicts around the world
he's now talking about afghanistan you
had some strong
cautions for him but here's what he said
about bringing those folks home from
afghanistan
we've been there 19 years we're not
really
um let's put it this way we're more
policemen than anything else
and that's not for our soldiers we could
win the war in afghanistan
in less than a week but i'm not looking
to kill 10 million
people and i'm not talking nuclear what
are your concerns about bringing
everyone home all u.s
operations from that area every
commander i've talked to
the intelligence community says that
al-qaeda and
isis are re-emerging in afghanistan that
if we draw all
if we withdraw all of our forces they
can hit us in the region and here at
home
this is exactly what they told president
obama
it is not right to right to leave if
we'd had a
residual force in iraq there would be no
isis isis has now moved to afghanistan
along with al qaeda
my belief is that a small
counterterrorism force
will protect the american homeland from
another 911
it's just not me saying that it is the
intelligence community and every
military commander
president trump has done a great job of
rebuilding the military he's gone after
isis and syria and iraq
we've got their foot on we've got our
foot on their throat if we pull
all of our troops out it will we just
matter of time in my view
do they regenerate the good news is a
very small counterterrorism force
is an insurance policy against another
911
and i hope the president will see it
that way and follow the advice of his
commanders and if he gets in the debate
with joe biden here's what i would
recommend the president to do aren't you
the guy that gave us isis aren't you the
guy that told
uh we're getting out no matter what the
military says mr president don't go down
the joe biden barack obama road when it
comes to afghanistan
this is where the whole thing started
and we got to get afghanistan right in
the good news
is with a few thousand counter-terrorism
forces we can protect america
for a very long time to come and we can
reduce the cost
and we should reduce the cost all right
senator lindsey graham live from
greenville south carolina tonight thank
you sir
thank you